hey guys for overhaul ark has finally
begun with episode 2 of the new season
dropping yesterday now let's be real
here guys for everyone who's read the
manga there was one moment and one
moment only that we've all been waiting
to see that scene where overhaul makes
magma explode like an egg in a microwave
let's just take a step back and analyze
why this moment was absolutely perfect
in episode 2 firstly the direction here
is phenomenal the way the camera like
pans and overhauls hand as he takes off
his glove and then the music immediately
stops as soon as he makes contact with
Magnus arm all we could hear at that
moment was the sound of his finger
making contact and then BOOM
but by far the best thing about this to
me and the thing that elevates it above
the manga panel which I love is how they
showed us every detail of how Magna was
about to explode from the inside out
like we see her skin begin to bulge into
all these little balls and then just
erupt into a bloody explosion like it
was awesome and then obviously we get
this cool negative shot which is then
followed by the blood splattering effect
all over the screen they really put a
lot of thought and effort into this and
I appreciate it and I love this shot
where it shows everyone's different
reactions to what overhaul has just done
especially twice because I mean he is
very very stressed out after being the
one to bring overhaul to the base only
for him to kill one of your members but
you know I'm kind of of the opinion that
magnet deserved it because think about
it if you live in a world where 80% of
people have superpowers you better be
sure that your quirk is unbeatable
before you go around threatening people
you know nothing about right sadly this
is not a lesson that anyone taught
magner so you hate to see her also rest
in peace to this man
we'd never knew your name but I'm gonna
assume it wasn't just shield this guy
stepped in to protect over all like he
was the president but where was he
hiding that whole time and how did he
get in front of all so quickly like
unless he has a speed quirk I don't know
how he did that
but regardless getting dusted like this
is not how I want to go out another
great thing about this scene is that we
got introduced to the other members of
the eight precepts of death who all look
very awesome in color I might add if you
want to know more about their quirks
then check out my xi his hai cái'
explainer video I'm not exactly sure if
I said that right she has shy his no she
his I KY shy his like a whatever and
finally the last highlight of this scene
was mister compris having his quirk
stripped away and then getting his arm
eviscerated in one swoop and i can't be
the only one who thought the reaction of
or skin was kind of gross no wonder he
was so angry with people touching him
and regarding the actual plot now
instead of just the fight scenes I guess
it was kind of cool to see overall ro
chaga rocky over his mismanagement of
the league of villains mainly because
he's not wrong
Shigure rocky at this point in the story
at least has yet to display any of the
leadership or resourcefulness when
compared to all for one but we do start
to see the beginnings of that potential
he maintained a bit of restraint in not
letting toga go after that she has I Chi
and he kind of like begins to mull over
what overhall said to him about needing
a plan so this is kind of like planting
the seeds of potentially what is to come
but let's get into the remainder of the
episode so it was pretty decent I didn't
have any complaints we managed to get an
extra scene with the big three where
Mario makes another dad joke that once
again falls flat but I appreciate the
effort and I know some people were
complaining online about how Miriah
looks this season and when compared to
the manga I can kind of see that
criticism but I would say that when I
was watching this episode when he's in
motion I didn't actually notice any
problems it's only when you screenshot
it has specific moments that I see what
people are getting at but like I said
when I watched the episode this never
occurred to me so essentially the second
half of the episode is Deku trying to
secure a work-study with sir Knight I
and just to do another quick plug if you
want to get the lowdown on sir Knight I
then be sure to check out my sir not a
video but anyway all might refuses to
introduce Deku tonight I for three
reasons that I won't go into here the
reason I mention this is because I loved
her as he was explaining his reasons all
the other teachers were just like
eavesdropping and chipping in with their
opinions which was very true to the
manga and quite funny as well all might
then ask Mario if he would be the one to
introduce Deku and this was a great
moment that stood out to me
Mario is intently gazing at the scars on
deck whose arms before he says yes that
was a little detail that I'm pretty sure
was not in the manga I might be wrong
but I'm fairly certain it wasn't and
what makes it so awesome is because we
know that miryo has a ton of scars on
his own arm from trying to master his
quirk and so he knows how determined
Deku is to become number one because he
has gone down this exact same path of
mastering a quote that was at first very
harmful to use and finally the episode
ends with this shot of sir Knight I
watching old all my YouTube videos
before Deku miryo just burst in only to
discover that night I is basically
delivering some kind of
dream tickle torture which if you see it
out of context is pretty bizarre but the
reason this was happening is because
night I values humor and laughter so
ridiculously highly and that was the
reason why before they entered the
building maybe a kind of Warren deku to
make night I laugh before the meeting
was over I loved how the director added
this extra scene of midoriya practicing
his all my impression over the years
that was absolutely brilliant
however night I takes this attempt at
humor completely the wrong way and
that's how the episode ends on a pretty
light-hearted note so for me it ended
exactly where I needed to we started
with the introduction of overhaul we got
to see a demonstration of his amazing
power and we also got tons of me real
content so you can't complain about that
so overall for me personally this
episode was very satisfying I got the
one moment I wanted and then everything
else was pretty cool as well so that's
why I'm giving this episode episode 2 of
season 4 an 8.5 out of 10 it was paced
very well and it introduced us to the
beginnings of the overall arc but what
did you guys rate the episode let me
know in the comments below if you
enjoyed that video then please check out
my explainer content where I go and
delve into the backstories and quirks
and personalities of a variety of
different characters including ones that
were introduced in this episode and let
me know what characters you'd like to
see analyzed in the future peace guys